um i'm you know because we've done well
here on the show and uh you know that's
no secret to anyone and we're you know
grateful to all the fans for that
uh i've decided to get a personal
trainer and this is something that i
have put off doing for a long time and
uh and i it's out of fear but i finally
found somebody that i think
i connected with and somebody who i look
at as an example
of what i think i can do
and that's big to me to find someone who
i look at a certain body type but look
at somebody i go
that's out of reach or that's something
that i can't do but this is someone who
i met with we had a consultation
he understood my limitations and he he
understands the potential there
and uh
i'm excited about this and i think that
it'll be
it'll challenge me you know this will be
something that um
you know i don't
you know take lightly this is something
that i'm really gonna now really try to
do
with this person who i think who's i'm
fully committed and and they're fully
committed and they have represented some
people
you know and they've you know coached i
don't even know the term trained
some of the most famous people in the
world um
so this is
my personal trainer pat
i was ralph mae's personal trainer and
you see how that went he really tried to
pull the guy at least i got his money
yeah
well he did work with ralphie at the end
and i don't think we can look at the
results
i think we have to look at the journey
and i think the journey was valuable and
i think even though that didn't
necessarily end in a way that
you know
is positive i think
i don't think it's your fault i think
you certainly
did the best and what what are your
plans for me what should i really be i
mean looking forward to and what what
should i be kind of like focused on
lots of walking
yeah well we can do that
we certainly can do that but again this
is someone who gets me
and he gets
what i'm capable of
and so many trainers when i've met with
them don't and they push me
uh pat has said i don't really or
shouldn't even think about going to a
gym for three to four years
which i think is important to just kind
of start slow
and isn't that right pat you said i
should just really not push myself
and this is something that i'm not
trained lizzio to
yeah he's trained lizzo and he they're
getting very serious now
with lizzo you know and i saw
you know liza kind of walking you around
the mall and kind of pushing you around
and i think that's that's good that's
where i'm going to start
we're starting just kind of moving pat
through
certain
you know areas
it's amazing when you meet someone who
has a passion for fitness
that pat does because i have not you
know my whole life i haven't had one but
pat has kind of showed me that fitness
isn't
necessarily any one thing fitness could
mean many many things
and
the passion that he has
for fitness
and what he's been able to do at one
time i think he weighed over four or 500
pounds
and what he's been able to do
you know with his body is completely is
very impressive
um and i i am just in awe
of that and it's something that i want
to emulate
and this is breathing is even a workout
too yes yes breathing is
and that's what he told me because
breath control and breathing is is
probably the most important thing and
that i shouldn't
really get into weights or cardio to
just kind of just the in and the out
in and the out the in and the out
are you are you taking on any
new clients right now is there
is there anything that you're excited
about is there anything that you want to
promote are you promoting any fitness
programs because i don't want to keep
all this to myself
you know there's a lot of people out
there that need help and
one thing i've learned is that when you
have something good you want to give it
away you want to share it because that
becomes you know a really important
part of
the journey
of growth is not hoarding
the knowledge sharing it freely
with other people
and pat has a lot just you hopefully you
won't die like ralph did
well that's the goal
that is certainly the goal
but we go we go nice and slow
that's what we've learned slow and
steady wins the race
and that's what pat has always said we
don't want to move too quickly we don't
want to disrupt the systems
that we've come to rely on and uh
it's really amazing you know how you've
inspired me and i want to thank you
again
for everything that you've done
not only for me but for several other
people that in this business that you've
worked with and you know the trainers
don't get a lot of attention you know
nobody nobody calls
and says hey what a great job
but you've you've you've done a lot and
uh it's i really am i'm excited to to
work with you and to see where this
relationship goes i think it's just
going to be amazing and a lot of people
are
very excited that i've chosen pat
you know because a lot of people were
worried that i would choose you know one
of these la [ __ ]
trainers but i chose someone who i
believe is inspiring and committed it's
been an amazing uh
time we've worked together for two
months we haven't really
done anything yet
physically
but
the point is to really just kind of
fully you know he has me reading through
the history
of
gyms and personal fitness and exercise
writing a lot about that
and
you know just reading a lot of theory
and that's where i think
the other trainers don't work hard like
i do that's a good point a lot of them
don't and it's unfortunate
and it's something that
i think
you know is is really amazing is that
when you find somebody who who gets it
and uh i wanna thank you and i just
wanna i hope that you don't give up on
me
just don't give up on me
that's all i'm asking i know sometimes
it might be frustrating but
we're in this for the long haul i just
i'm i'm just hoping that you are in this
as well for the long haul with me this
is uh
you know it's just you're a spectacular
find
and uh i hope you're as committed to
this as i am
i will never give up on you but it's a
really good paycheck
well there you have it this is my new
personal trainer pat
thank you so much for everything we we
appreciate it and again if you're
interested in in training with pat
uh contact me via dm and we'll get you
his information because he's absolutely
one of the best
thank you so much